there are a few franchises that have
been churning out movies semi-regularly
since the early 1960s
even fewer have brought the kind of box
office results that break records
and there's really only one named after
a character so suave that grown men
immediately feel an overwhelming desire
to imitate
him when they put on a tuxedo when it
comes to these criteria no one does it
better than
bond james bond
sean connery was the original official
james bond bringing the character from
the pages of intelligence officer turned
writer ian fleming's novels to the big
screen
his first adventure was 1962's doctor no
which cost one million dollars to make
and earned nearly 60 million dollars
worldwide a little over 509 million
dollars in 2020 money the role brought
connory fame
fortune and an eternal association with
an iconic character
but the famously brash and borderline
reclusive connery who passed away at the
age of 90 in october 2020
wasn't just a member of the exclusive
list of actors who have played bond he
also has a metaphorical membership to
the club of actors who regret the role
that made them famous
this is the reason sean connery
regretted playing james bond
connery was lucky to land the role of
bond according to the late richard
maybaum known for his screenplay
adaptations of the bond novels
fleming thought david niven would be a
great james bond roger moore was also
considered for the parts early on
connery's bad boy vibe ultimately won
him the puss but the success of dr no
quickly turned his big break
into an all-encompassing headache
connery was dismissive of the bond films
while he was still making them
in 1964 when his third bond outing
goldfinger was in production
connery told an interviewer that bond
was just a dull prosaic english
policeman when all the exotic touches
were removed he could have been
demonstrating unique modesty but it
certainly sounds like he didn't think
very highly of bonn
in november 1965 connery admitted to
reports that he was already fed up to
here with the whole bond bit
though conory said at the time that he
shouldn't knock bond and said in a
november
1964 interview with the new york times
that he'd be everlastingly grateful to
the character his attitude changed over
the years
by the time he was shooting you only
lived twice released in 1967
connery had fallen out with producer
albert cubby broccoli who'd been
instrumental in getting him hired it
didn't help that he was stalked and
chased by paparazzi during filming or
that he felt his salary was too low you
only live twice was meant to be
connery's last bond appearance but he
returned for 1971's diamonds are forever
though not out of love for the character
in a 1971 interview with the guardian
connery made it clear that he resented
the studio executives for wasting his
time
i'd been messed about too much on other
bond pictures there's so much bull
that comes from bad decisions being made
at the top connery struck a deal to be
paid ten thousand dollars per week if
the film shoot ran over the scheduled 18
weeks he added
talking to some of these moguls about it
is like trying to describe to someone
who has never taken exercise
what it is like to feel fit when you do
exercise they don't understand
apparently connory only agreed to make
the movie having skipped 1969's on her
majesty's secret service
because he was given a large percentage
of profits and the opportunity to
produce two movies of his choice
and connery wasn't done with bond money
yet he returned for the appropriately
titled never say never again
reportedly for around five million
dollars amidst all that connery made it
clear how he felt about the character
that launched his career via the
guardian
i've always hated that damned james bond
i'd like to kill him
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and to
the bell so you don't miss
a single one